well I for one I'm saying Merry
Christmas again thanks president Trump
Donald Trump talks in tweets a lot like
honestly is stunning him out it's a
whole lot
it's mucho you get the idea I have spent
a lot of 20:18 a lot reading the
transcripts of what he says whether it's
on Twitter and presidential dresses or
while he was on the campaign trail for
other candidates throughout the year
it's been it's been a thing now whether
you like president Trump or you love him
I can tell you that he has whatever the
opposite of a way with words is he just
says stuff sometimes if you are
listening to or watching his speeches
you might miss how totally weird and
nonsensical parts of them are but I can
assure you that if you are reading his
words as I have spent countless hours
doing over the past 365 days the utter
strangeness of what Trump says literally
leaps off the page at you so before we
turn the page on 2018 I wanted to share
with you the 10/10 wildest wackiest and
well just plain weird things that the
President of the United States had said
over the last year let's do this we have
the worst immigration laws in the entire
world this is Trump's regular refrain on
the nation's immigration laws which he
insists have to be changed and made
tougher of course Trump is poised to
sign a bill funding the government
through January that has no more dollars
dedicated to his border wall so so I
give myself an A+ throughout the past
year Donald Trump has been asked by
interviewers to give himself a letter
grade based on what he believes to be
his performance in office now most
people and certainly most presidents
would say something like I don't know a
beer maybe an a-minus you know to give
themselves some room for improvement
nah Trump a plus and he is even said he
would give himself a higher grade than a
plus if that existed which it doesn't I
explored that very very deeply in grade
school we're all fighting about us
but I love fight on these battles this
may be the truest thing Donald Trump
said in 2018 no one loves a fight more
than him if he isn't fighting someone he
feels like he isn't living right he
finds his definition by being against
someone or something he often refers to
himself as a counter-puncher but there's
no question he will start the fight when
he thinks he needs to do you ever have
second thoughts about literally every
second of every day of my waking life
which makes me very different than
Donald Trump he starts every day with
not a care in the world for what he said
yesterday or the day before and whatever
he does that day is the distant past by
tomorrow what a life the greatest phrase
I think in the history of politics is on
all of those red and white hats that I
see out there make America great again
okay quick rankings of the greatest
phrases in the history of politics at
number three the only thing we have to
fear is fear itself from Franklin Delano
Roosevelt at to ask not what your
country can do for you ask what you can
do for your country
from John F Kennedy and at number one
drum roll please make America great
again by Donald John Trump those are
definitive rankings you cannot disagree
that just shows when you get good
ratings you can say anything right
this is Donald Trump's worldview boiled
down to just 12 words his biggest fear
in life and in politics isn't bad press
it's no press death for him is people no
longer being interested in what he says
and tweets which is why he says in
tweets so much on a daily basis and when
you're talking about an atmosphere
oceans are very small and it blows over
and it sails over what a way to explain
his skepticism about climate change
right Trump must not have accounted for
the fact that these very small oceans do
cover 70% of the Earth's surface even
one of them recently said that President
Trump made promises buddies
captain many more promises I mean far
more than I made think of it honestly
there's so much here where to start
first Trump goes third person to refer
to himself and Chris Alissa approves
second he says he has kept more promises
than he's made in his first two years in
office which I'm pretty sure is totally
impossible
we love winners sway love winners
winners are winners winners are winners
it's it's so so true I joke but never
forget that in Trump's mind the ends
always justify the means if you win you
must have done the right thing because
winning is the only goal that truly
matters do you remember two things
number one I said we're gonna be saying
Christmas again and number two I said I
was gonna give you a Christmas present
Donald Trump said this on February 5th
2018 but man it is so relevant right
about now merry freaking Christmas and
that is the point read my entire list of
trumps top lines 41 of them over at
cnn.com we do this thing every week
twice come get fresh new content every
Tuesday and Thursday